mr. know-it-all what's the rule of thumb
unexpired medicines my just popped a
past its prime tylenol and it seemed to
work fine
are those expiration dates just a
corporate racket drug companies tend to
err on the side of caution and they're
not exactly averse to selling you a new
bottle of pills before your old one is
empty
the FDA once evaluated a US military
stockpile of ageing drugs and found that
90% was perfectly safe and effective
past their expiration dates now one of
those meds a remedy for of all things
nerve gas poisoning still worked after
sitting on a shelf 15 years longer than
recommended
of course shelf-life will fluctuate
based on environmental factors such as
temperature and humidity a bottle of
aspirin in a moderate climate like
California's will age slower than in an
extreme climate like Flores though pain
relievers never expire in Florida on
account of its geriatric population
burning through them like candy so if
you take an expired pill and it doesn't
work just buy a new bottle or switch to
homeopathic medicine which never expires
because it never works in the first
place
I'm mr. know-it-all
which means I already know whether or
not you are interested in clicking on
the subscribe button you are
you